[Aplausos]
uno de los medios más grandes más
importantes que tiene la humanidad desde
muchísimo desde es muchísimo tiempo
desde épocas inmemoriales desde tiempos
antiquísimos incluso me atrevo a decir
desde que se empezaron a generar las
relaciones humanas revistas encuestas
muchos modelos lo han considerado como
el segundo miedo más importante que
tiene la humanidad incluso hay algunos
que los señalan como el primero
cuando uno se encuentra aquí parado en
este punto en este espacio tiempo
cuando todo el auditorio convergen
cuando todas las miradas se juntan
llegan a este punto es una de las
sensaciones de verdad más temidas más
terroríficas que una persona puede
experimentar les ha pasado
obviamente por qué pasa esto pareciera
ser que la respuesta es un tanto
complicada la verdad es que no es muy
sencilla la realidad es que nos preocupa
demasiado lo que digan las personas de
nosotros lo que digan las personas y
nosotros lo que opinen lo pongo así la
opinión de los demás acerca de nosotros
nos preocupa muchísimo es un adorado
tesoro vale oro entonces cuando yo me
posiciono aquí que puede pasar pues que
sea dorado tesoro se pierda o
simplemente ese oro se convierte en
carbón
alguna vez le ha pasado a alguien eso
no bueno
he escuchado a mucha gente tener
proyectos extraordinarios de verdad
magníficos proyectos innovadores que
pueden cambiar al mundo pero porque no
lo han compartido bueno la mente empieza
a maquinar que cuando yo esté aquí y si
no hago una buena actuación que creen y
si me empiezan a temblar las piernas y
si no empiezo a hablar correctamente el
mundo se acabó es decir mi oportunidad
frente a un público para poder
expresarme estará ordenada y mi vida se
acabará
entonces empieza a maquinar la mente y
lo curioso de esto lo más chistoso es
que ni siquiera existe nos hemos
posicionado aquí muchas veces y la
cuestión es que no nos hemos atrevido a
dar este paso de hablar en público
estamos a tras bambalinas pero nunca
hablar en público y es por eso que yo
creo que estoy aquí
ojo quiero advertir algo así como lo
hacían tú andes en superí antes de leer
su libro yo no vengo aquí a darles las
mejores técnicas para hablar en público
la guía absoluta para conmover a un
público y pueda ser el mejor orador de
toda la vida nada de eso es más ni
siquiera les vengo a decir cómo eliminar
el miedo que dicho sea de paso el miedo
no se elimina el miedo se transforma se
canaliza y se utiliza hecho esta
advertencia empecemos
dicen los que saben del tema de hablar
en público los grandes oradores que hay
dos elementos que se deben de cuidar
aquí que deben estar en constante
equilibrio forma y fondo la forma como
lo digo es decir si estoy importando la
voz si lo estoy diciendo bien si no me
estoy trabajando si estoy ocupando todo
este espacio que lo estoy haciendo
correctamente decir el como lo estoy
haciendo
el segundo es el fondo que quieres esto
el contenido lo que estoy diciendo es
útil a las personas les puede servir a
las personas
yo creo y en este pequeño trayecto de
vida que tengo que faltan ciertos
elementos aparte de estos dos no voy en
contra de la oratoria clásica pero sí
creo que hacen falta unos elementos más
y pues se supone que una charla tesis
para estudiar nada pues para escuchar
una historia les voy a contar mi
historia de vida que hasta hace apenas
un año me enteré de esto
pero antes yo ya les había comentado
cuál es el segundo miedo más importante
que tiene la humanidad estamos de
acuerdo
y hablar en público cuál creen que sea
el primer miedo que tiene la humanidad
a ver aquí
morir tal vez
aquí morir alguien que no tenga miedo a
la muerte acá fracasar sí por supuesto
fracasar otro uno más
hacer el ridículo pues sí bueno
realmente ése no sea miedo número uno
saben cuál es el miedo número uno
que tu mamá te preste un tope y lo
pierdas ese sí es un miedo fatal y más
si esto pero muere porque es de los
buenos
eso sí su miedo
me lo contó un experto
este es la primera lección que yo les
quiero compartir hay que eliminar la
barrera que está entre quien habla y
quien escucha y cómo podemos eliminar
esa barrera hay un método sencillo
cualquier que sea
hacer reír a la gente no hay nada más
simpático que hacer reír a la gente de
verdad misma no les ha pasado sí sí sí
todos tenemos una tía un primo que se
ríe y a veces no los ritmos de su
anécdota o del chiste que contó nos
reímos de su risa pues aquí tiene un
familiar sí cierto no no hay nada más
poderoso que la risa
ojo no lo recomiendo cuando los invitan
a hablar a un funeral no
las consecuencias y pueden ser este
contrarias hay que tener mucho cuidado
al rato se van a ir a la caja con el
muertito pero bueno
estaba cursando mi último semestre de la
licenciatura
yo estudié en la facultad de derecho y
normalmente cuando uno ya está a punto
de concluir sus estudios se genera un
comité organizador que hace este comité
organizador genera los eventos sociales
y culturales de la propia generación muy
saludables por cierto
bueno por lo menos los abogados y los
hacemos así muy saludables
este comité una de las actividades que
hacen normalmente es la última cátedra
que es la última cátedra bueno la última
cátedra es precisamente que todos los
alumnos elijan a los maestros que los
marcaron y nos den por decirlo así los
últimos consejos ya para dirigirnos a la
vida laboral
dentro de este concepto de la última
cátedra se le da la oportunidad para que
uno o dos alumnos puedan pasar a hablar
y pues decir algo así como el discurso
de generación para esto mis amigos del
comité organizador tuvieron la magnífica
idea de generar un concurso de oratoria
para ver quién iba a dar el último
discurso generación nuevas para ponerlos
en contexto facultad de derecho
ya se imaginarán la clase de oradores
que pasaron la facultad de hecho ha dado
oradores importantes durante mucho
tiempo al país
hablando de la justicia de la verdad de
esa obligación de los abogados que
tienen para con el bien común y charlan
a la verdad es que debo contar
confesarles que cuando estaba
escribiendo mis cosas de verdad sin
licencias y dije voy a poner una
frasecita de monte es que uno para que
se oiga chica una vez hicieron algo
romántico con winston churchill o sea
algo así para qué quieren ir los atrape
y dicho y hecho muchos compañeros
hicieron así y de verdad no me peleo con
la notaria clásica extraordinarios
discursos que dieron pero al momento de
que yo estaba escribiendo mi discurso me
di cuenta de algo muy importante la
última vez que yo quería estar con mis
amigos así verlos de frente era
hablarles de justicia y de verdad y de
esa obligación que tenemos los abogados
yo les quería hablar de aquello que
dicen que es invisible a los ojos y que
solo se ve bien con el corazón les
quería hablar de lo que vimos durante
cinco años y eso se me ocurrió un día
antes del concurso pero aún así lo hice
entonces pues que creen que pasó en este
concurso
no nos gane
me dieron la oportunidad de participar
entonces me dieron la oportunidad de
poder hablar frente a mis amigos por una
simple y sencilla razón cuando estaba
escribiendo mi discurso abrir aquello
que les dije que es esencial hable de
los extras a los que nos fuimos hablé de
las fiestas hablé de los trabajos de los
maestros de todas las horas que vivimos
juntos porque porque compartí cinco años
con ellos ellos son de mí como yo de
ellos cinco años o sea es un buen de
tiempo
y la cuestión aquí es que mis amigos no
son mis amigos para que no salga
nepotismo este no la opción es que mis
compañeros del comité lo que hicieron
fue elegirme porque no dio el mejor
discurso tiene que saberlo no soy un
gran orador aclaro para que no tengan
ahí este no se sorprendan la cuestión es
de que me eligieron porque hablé con
pasión cuando yo estaba diciendo a
dislexia gracias por los cinco años que
pasamos juntos lo hice con pasión con
honestidad
yo sé lo que hace falta hoy en día
hablar con el corazón si tú no hablas
con pasión con honestidad si no hablas
con el corazón la gente lo nota mira la
gente que te ve con estas hablan en
público te puede perdonar que te
equivoques de verdad que no hagas el
mejor discurso pero jamás te va a
perdonar que no seas honesto nunca jamás
te va a perdonar que no seas honesto
normalmente se piensa que para hablar en
público uno tiene primero que hablar
bien y luego ya se va a dar la pasión
para darles algún día las redes que no
lo que primero se está es tener la
pasión todo lo demás y es consecuente y
esa es la primera lección que yo aprendí
a estas apenas un año y que yo les
quiero compartir a ustedes de que
siempre que se paren aquí en este punto
hablen desde el corazón hablen con
pasión y hablen con honestidad lo que me
lleva al segundo punto que aprendí sabes
bien yo siempre en la facultad de hecho
me gustó mucho los debates legislativos
mucho el tema de la grilla por decir la
siguiente entra de la facultad de no
fuera y la verdad es que en los debates
pues siempre se da ese tema técnico
saben de ese tema de economía de
hacienda todo eso todo es relajo pero yo
siempre me distingue por una cosa
cuando yo pasaba a debatir siempre le
metía ese film amoroso de verdad amoroso
y luego decir por qué
yo soy esa persona típica mala copa
que a la una de la mañana ya empieza a
poner a joaquín sabina a jose jose me
gusta toda esa bohemia y todo eso me
gusta transportarlo a como soy yo en la
vida diaria entonces cuando participaban
nuestros debates cuando me dije a mis
amigos yo siempre ha sido así me encanta
la bohemia me encanta y si es esa
sensación yo creo que muchos aquí la
compartimos no fernando delgadillo una
turista siempre ha sido ese ese tema
film
me eligieron porque fui congruente
siempre me había expresado así me gusta
el amor me gusta la bohemia me gusta
sentir cosas o yo se piensa que la
comunicación solamente es auditiva o
visual realidades que no hoy la
comunicación es emocional tú sientes
cuando una persona está siendo honesta o
cuando está engañando
entonces
aquí quiero llegar con este punto que
cuando usted parece aquí tienes que ser
congruente no voy a ponerme a hablar de
cambio climático cuando ni siquiera en
mi casa tengo la noción de poder separar
los residuos por ejemplo tiene que haber
congruencia siempre que uno se para aquí
hay una frase que me encanta y es muy
común pero pues es la neta la palabra
halal
pero el ejemplo el ejemplo arrastra no
hay nada más congruente que lo hagas con
el ejemplo y es el segundo punto que
tienen que entender cuando estén aquí
tienen que hablar con google
[Música]
para los
y que éxitos y quitarnos ese ego de que
el más importante en este momento es
quien habla eso es mentira uno tiene que
entender que cuando esté aquí tienes una
obligación y cuál es esa obligación
darle a las personas que escuchan algo
que les sirva que sea útil
y esto me lleva al cuarto punto y final
lo más importante que tenemos en esta
vida lo más importante no puedo
conseguir otra cosa más importante es el
tiempo en que dedicamos nuestro tiempo
va a definir de verdad seguimos
plenamente no el tiempo lo esto
entonces imaginen que tengo aquí a más
de 100 personas que me están dando lo
más valioso que tienen si el tiempo si
uno no está agradecido con ello de
verdad no sé qué hacemos aquí hablando
frente a un público
necesitamos ser agradecidos la verdad
que yo quiero agradecer a todos ustedes
que me estén escuchando a los que
lleguen a ver este vídeo si lo llegan a
ver pero en especial a aquellas personas
que tienen un sueño que tienen grandes
proyectos bien hoy el mundo el mundo es
caótico de verdad vivimos con pobreza
vivimos con hambre cambio climático ni
se diga hace una semana acabe de sacarla
una encuesta en donde si no hacemos algo
para el 2050 se acabó literal se acabó
entonces de verdad a esas personas el
mundo les quiere escuchar el mundo las
necesita
pero si y sólo si hablan con pasión sí y
sólo si son congruentes son honestos y
hablan desde el corazón sí y sólo si el
mundo te quiere escuchar si vas a
aportar algo para cambiar la situación
actual si y sólo si eres agradecido con
dios y con la vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]